they say you can spend money here but
you can't spend money there perhaps it's
always been like this and it's just
becoming more obvious hey guys I'm off
the grid for August but my man across
the pond Russell Brand making sense as
usual have a look at it in more detail a
petition to stop Australia from becoming
a cashless Society has gained more than
120 000 signatures as Banks increasingly
restrict customers access to their money
which doesn't seem like what a bank
should be doing the meaning of words is
continually changing the function of
Institutions is changing compassion and
kindness means that you just can't talk
anymore and now banks are an institution
that prevent you from getting your money
in Australia more than sixteen hundred
Bank branches permanently shut their
doors between June 2017 and July 2022.
while the remaining big four Banks
Commonwealth ANZ and NAB have all opened
cashless branches where customers are
directed to ATMs for everyday banking
all big four banks have also introduced
restrictions on customers sending large
amounts to cryptocurrency exchanges and
Associated sites you can't have your
money and neither can you set up any
alternatives to these systems that we're
determined to impose upon you Authority
is migrating unquestioned to new
locations when did your relationship
with your bank become a relationship in
which you were subjugated where they say
you can spend money here but you can't
spend money there perhaps it's always
been like this and it's just becoming
more obvious and more plain but really
the role of a bank is supposed to be a
role of service in fact all of these
institutions are supposed to be set up
to be in your service but isn't it
becoming increasingly obvious that we're
becoming secondary and subjugated
subordinate to the will of some not
fully revealed but plainly present
Central Authority the bank can now take
your money and control where you can
spend it you're not able to speak freely
authoritarianism appears to be on the
rise I feel that new tyranny will not be
in the form of demagogic figures that
talk about nationalism but in this creep
of liberal bureaucracies that just down
your ability to do anything without ever
fully explaining it or allowing you to
vote for it